ويشكل الوضع الانساني في اقليم تكراي
الجانب الاكثر اهميه في مفاوضات الحكومه
الاثيوبيه والجبهه تجري حيث تعطل وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه للاقليمذون ديار
الهدنه شهر اغسطس الماضي بحسب دراسه
لجامعه جانيت البلجيكيه فمن اجمالي سوكاي
البالغ عددهم حوالي سته ملايين نسمه نزح
اكثر من مليون شخص من تقراي وامهر
وفرنسانا في القتال وذلك بعد ما صاروا غير
قادرين على جنه محاصرهم وافاد تقرير
لمنظمه اليونيسيف ان العمل الانسانيه
يتطلب توفيره اكثر من 530 مليون دولار
امريكي
لتلبيه الحاجات الانسانيه الحرجه في
اثيوبيا
ووفقها تقرير لمكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
الشؤون الانسانيه فان الصراع في شمال
اثيوبيا يتسبب في تعطيل اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف في مرفق الصحي وانها حواليه سبع مئه
الف طفل فاتتهم التطعيمات الروتين»